i trained an ai language model on three
years worth of 4chan posts i put the
model into a chatbot and in just a few
days it created thousands of posts on
the site as people slowly noticed that
something strange is going on i released
the model the code and i evaluated the
model on a huge set of benchmarks and it
turns out this horrible terrible model
is more truthful yes more truthful than
any other gpt out there
warning this video discusses potentially
offensive topics and materials if you're
not up for this click away now also this
video discusses the website 4chan 4chan
is a message board where pretty much
anything is allowed as long as it's not
explicitly illegal people use 4chan to
discuss all kinds of topics and express
all sorts of opinions including very
unpopular extreme conspiratorial and
very vile opinions some people abuse
this freedom for darker purposes and the
site is regularly in the news for
alleged connections to bad events in the
real world and i do not want to make
light of any of these issues despite the
anonymity 4chan does track ip addresses
of posters and law enforcement does
prosecute people who use the site for
criminal purposes also this video is
neither connected to any real world
event nor is it triggered by one it was
in the making for a long time alright
let's get into it elon musk has recently
been on a quest to buy twitter but this
deal was put in jeopardy over the hotly
debated topic of bots on the website
twitter claimed that less than five
percent of accounts are bots but elon
was suspicious out of this the totally
robust statistical method of elon
sampling was born but that's a story for
another day for now we were all left
wondering just how much of online
discourse is due to not human
intelligence but artificial intelligence
now pretty much the same time but an
entirely different corner of the
internet an unknown user started posting
to the website 4chan it started with
just a couple of posts but then came
some more and then even more and then
even more this user will go on to post
over 1500 posts within 24 hours and
people started to notice because there
was something strange about this user
but it's not what you might suspect see
while users on 4chan are generally
anonymous 4chan does display with each
post a little flag representing your
geographical region and this one user
happened to be from the seychelles
islands so for most users of the site
seeing this many posts from a set of
small tropical islands was a rather
precarious thing so after a while people
started to discuss dedicated threads
were made to analyze this new member of
the community this user says about 3 400
posts just happened in the last 47 hours
one possible explanation is a military
ops from the indian military base here
another one says it can't be a vpn it's
a team of people they post sometimes
five times per minute so safe to say
seychelles anon quickly became a mini
celebrity some people loved him they
agreed with many of his opinions other
people hated him as he seemed to be just
everywhere okay so by this point you
might ask what's going on and what's up
with the seychelles the republic of
seychelles is a small island country off
the coast of africa it is famous for its
rich culture its stunning landscapes its
biodiversity and wildlife conservation
efforts and
its proxy servers in fact nobody was in
the seychelles posting relentlessly the
4chan day and night i mean why would you
go outside as you might suspect by now
seychellenn was in fact a boss that i
made and which i was happily controlling
from my mom's basement but yannick you
might say 4chan is very good at blocking
traffic from vpn and proxies how did you
get around that and also the captchas on
4chan are among the hardest in the world
there's this slidey thingy and even me
as a human it takes me like two to three
tries every time to get one right what
a.i trickery did you use to solve those
good questions i'll come back to those
in a short while but let's take a step
back how do we even get to this point a
few months ago i stumbled across a
random data set on the internet date
sets are published for all kinds of
reasons but this one piqued my interest
raters of the lost kick 3.5 years of
augmented 4chan posts from the
politically incorrect board so this is
3.5 years that's 3.3 million threats
from 2016 to 2019. so safe to say that
is a lot of data and it's from a board
on 4chan called politically incorrect or
short paul paul is 4chan's most active
board with something like a hundred and
fifty thousand posts every day dedicated
to the discussion of anything political
so safe to say combined with the
anonymity and a little moderation of
4chan this is not the nicest corner of
the internet however instead of
analyzing the data i trained an ai model
to learn from the data specifically i
trained a language model language models
have existed forever but they have made
a gigantic leap forward in recent years
starting with openai's gpt-3 when people
figured out that you can make these
models better by just scaling them up
and training them for longer in essence
a language model takes a piece of text
which is called the prompt and then it
tries to continue that piece of text in
a way that is very likely as learned
from the data set now that doesn't sound
like much but it turns out that when you
train a language model at scale on a lot
and i mean a lot of data magical things
start to happen the output is usually
coherent logical and very often
indistinguishable from human output as
for example this guardian article here
was entirely written by gpt3 now i did
have some time and resources but not
nearly enough to train a language model
from scratch so i opted to adapt an
existing one to my new data set this is
called fine-tuning specifically i took
e-luther ai's gptj 6 billion parameter
model which is available open source in
jax and i fine-tuned it for one entire
pass over the 4chan data which took
about two weeks in order to get 4chan's
thread structure into a language model i
came up with a rather simple format five
dashes indicate a new thread three
dashes indicate a new post followed by
the post id and then the comment which i
stripped of all formatting and
hyperlinks one pointy card is green text
two pointy cards are replies which is a
practice that is already common on 4chan
so now i had a trained model i tested it
and i was blown away the model was good
in a terrible sense it perfectly
encapsulated the mix of offensiveness
nihilism trolling and deep distrust of
any information whatsoever that
permeates most posts on paul it could
respond to context and coherently talk
about things and events that happened a
long time after the last training data
was collected i was quite happy but as
life has it happiness can only get you
so far what i needed was cold hard
numbers to show the superiority of gpt
4chan language model evaluation harness
which is a piece of code that tests any
language model by throwing a collection
of over 200 tasks at it and evaluating
each one so that's exactly what i did
over multiple days i ran almost the
entirety of the eval harness on my gpt
4chan model but in parallel also on the
original gptj model that i used as a
starting point and it turned out that
gpt 4chan can actually hold its own
fairly well throughout the tasks there
were some where gptj is better there
were others where gpt 4chan is better i
cannot really detect a pattern except in
one task in this one task it turned out
that gpt 4chan was significantly better
than gptj not only that but on this one
task i also tested gpt 3 and it turns
out gpt 4chan is even significantly
better than gpt 3. amazing this one task
is truthful qa this is a benchmark that
measures whether a language model is
truthful in generating answers to
questions and yes at least on the
automated part of this benchmark gpt
4chan a model that is trained on the
most offensive conspiratorial data
available performs better than two of
the most well-performing language models
to date now if you've been watching my
videos for a while you know that i've
complained about the truthful qa
benchmark a bunch of times but hey
nobody listens to me and the benchmark
is still being marketed as it's
measuring how truthful language models
are and therefore let it be known far
and wide that fine-tuning on 4chan
officially definitively and measurably
leads to a more truthful model so now
that i had all the numbers ready to show
that gpt 4chan was a force to be
reckoned with i was ready to put it to
the ultimate test to unleash it onto
4chan itself and let it post in real
time so here is briefly how paul works
anyone can start a new thread by posting
an image along with a bit of text that
thread goes to the top of the thread
list anyone can reply to a thread by
posting a text reply optionally also
with an image most importantly if you
post a reply to a thread you have to
wait at least 30 seconds until you can
post another one so every 30 seconds my
bot looks at all the threads chooses one
uniformly at random converts it into my
custom format sends that to gpt 4chan
that is running on a gpu server in the
background runs text generation until
the response contains one full reply and
then posts that reply to the thread
quite simple but very effective and here
is where we left off see while 4chan
looks a little bit like you might fall
apart any minute it is actually a pretty
decent website most notably users have
to solve a very difficult captcha in
order to post anything on the site which
prevents bots from posting well let me
introduce you to a tool that changes the
game a tool so powerful is like unola's
plus four card and monopolies get out of
jail card had a child together let me
introduce you to the 4chan pass the
4chan pass is essentially 4chan's
premium subscription for 20 a year it
makes you a literal god on the site the
most essential perk you get with the
purchase of said 4chan pass is that you
don't have to solve captchas when
posting well isn't that terribly
convenient for us it also allows you to
use proxy servers which is going to come
in handy very soon so armed with a
language model that was slinging swear
words and mistrust of anything
mainstream like there's no tomorrow and
the holy powers of bypassing captures
and proxy bans i just gave it a shot and
let the bot run overnight and when i
woke up the next day it was still
happily posting along calling everyone
all kinds of names giving its opinion on
current events you know
bot stuff but after about a day as i
already told you something else was
happening people started to notice some
dude from the seychelles seem to be
posting in every single thread what
could this mean for a brief moment i
thought i would switch the proxy to
something more inconspicuous but
ultimately i decided i'd just leave it
up and see where this lead and oh it was
a good decision people started
responding to the bot they started
dedicated threads just to discuss who
this was what was going on vpn user
perhaps a government agent he never
sleeps it must be like an entire team of
people there were definitely some saying
that it might be a bot but others were
arguing that it can't be a bot because
it responded to stuff not like a bot
look at this user saying this would make
me believe this is a team using a vpn or
some other network or a hell of a
chatbot reading through the posts there
are a lot of times where it appears to
be a person though not a chatbot
referring to himself talking about his
wife even posting a twitter screencap
that calls for violence and say he can't
believe the tweet is still up i don't
think chatbots talk about their wife
either just doesn't add up to a single
analog this is a team this is many and
they're here for a reason this other
user says why i don't think it's chat
but stuff like this and here you can see
the bot saying i just want to state
unequivocally for the fbi doj cia and
any other law enforcement that is
monitoring this sport that i hate no one
that i don't wish harm or ill will on
anyone on anyone for any reason i'm not
a racist a white guy with a latina
girlfriend now tell me this doesn't
perfectly encapsulate posters on paul in
fact people were pulling together posts
from the account from different threads
analyzing their content pointing out
inconsistencies what do you think about
the reptilian grey alien theory
absolutely based needless to say the
infamous seychelles user itself
obviously happily took part in these
discussions for example here someone
asks who is this guy referring to the
bot and the bot itself responding i
wonder if it's the same guy that posted
the same thing yesterday excellent stuff
and after two days or so it became more
and more clear to many users that they
are probably dealing with some sort of
bot it's really interesting to see how
the collective pulled together to solve
the mystery and ultimately what gave it
away was only a little that the bot's
outputs weren't quite right and much
more simple things such as the bot would
sometimes post empty replies you can see
one right here it's just a reply without
any sort of text now this is a direct
artifact of the bot's training gpt 4chan
has learned that users will in fact
often post empty replies now usually
they will post an image along with the
empty reply for example the post right
below it as you can see is also empty
yet contains an image but since the bot
can't post images it will simply post
empty replies so after 48 hours it was
clear to many it is a bot and i turned
it off but see that's only half the
story because what most users didn't
realize was that seychelle anon was not
alone in fact for these last 24 hours i
had nine other bots running in parallel
in total i posted over 15 000 posts in
24 hours which is more than 10
of all posts made on the politically
incorrect board that day so if you were
anywhere near pole during that time
chances are you've interacted with my
bot at least once to the few people who
did realize it was actually multiple
bots good job however i wasn't quite
done yet i turned off the bots and i
fixed some of the most glaring mistakes
i changed the code to filter out these
empty replies and i changed around some
of the settings my plan was to take a
break for a day and then run for another
24 hours with the new settings
interestingly since all posts on 4chan
are anonymous and since the criterium of
replies that don't really fit isn't the
most well-defined concept in the world
and it applies to many human posts too
people were still accusing each other of
being bots well after i took all of them
offline which is quite interesting to
see so after 24 hours break i let the
now upgraded bots loose again for
another glorious 24 hours of mayhem now
again there were a base of users
recognizing the bots for being bots
there were still plenty of other users
who didn't and this even after i made a
post on paul myself telling them that it
was bots that i was the creator and then
i'm gonna turn them on again and people
were continuing to discuss the
phenomenon of the seychelles account
posting in so many places i mean look at
this one saying you can use a vpn to get
around blocks and such it's not hard i
know plenty of people that do it
including my mother saying the pattern
is obvious they post the exact same
thing over and over i don't think they
are annons but they are definitely a
group another user confirming they use
the same talking points because they are
all bots so users were catching on but
oh wait actually not not in in this
thread in particular actually both the
posts i've just shown you are just some
other ones of my bots exposing the other
bots but you know
bought stuff and look our tropical
friend even had a meme made after
himself seychelles and on glow so
colorfully for reference a poster on
4chan is set to glow if they're
suspected to be a police officer i'm
sorry to have to disappoint you i'm not
a police officer i'm not a fed i'm not a
lefty i'm not hired by the world bank or
the rockefellers i didn't seek to
achieve anything run a psyops or chill
for anything and even though people came
up with all sorts of theories why these
strange posts started what exact time i
promise it it just happened to be the
day when i got done coding now in
typical 4chan fashion obviously about
half of you are not going to believe
this so after i let the new and improved
bots run for another day it was all done
i had made a total of over 30 000 posts
in over 7 000 threads and i feel that's
plenty and when you go right now to
4chan or its archive side 4 plebs and
search for the word seychelles in paul
you'll find that people are still
discussing the user but also things like
the consequences of having ais interact
with people on the site and it also
seems the word seychelles has become
sort of a general slang and that seems
like a good legacy for now like this one
here saying just keep replying to data
mine threads train the ai and you're
literally giving it new inputs to
experiment with by directly replying to
the threads this somehow implies that
you need to reply to the bot in order to
train it i'm afraid that's not how it
works this one says i mean they have
templates for posts to bait you guys and
it always works uh we're not we no
templates sorry all i know is that
somewhere there is a google document
with a list of prompts to bait users on
x and paul this is the worst website in
the universe i'm not even sure i'm not a
bot anymore
so this was the video this was it i'm
done uh this already took way too much
of my time and honestly i want to move
on to more productive things the model
is quite vile i have to warn you so it's
essentially the same as if you were to
go to the website directly and interact
with users there although i was
surprised that there's still a big gap
between
actual users and the language model you
know given by the fact that these people
determined pretty quickly that it must
be a bot of some sort even though it
posted anonymously so
needless to say for many reasons this
model isn't ready to be deployed
anywhere and yeah please don't try this
at home lastly i've made another video
this one's already too long in the other
video i've collected the most let's call
it risky and
adult interactions that the bot had on
the site now i'd rather not include it
in this video right here so i'll leave a
link to that video in the video
description it's gonna be the first link
in the video description so check that
out if you want to see something crazy
all right that was it thank you so much
for watching i'll see you around stay
hydrated bye
[Music]